posez au coeur de l'océan indien entre
madagascar et la côte africaine un bout
de france c'est mayotte
ici les jeunes garçons construisent des
bang à des petites maisons à l'écart des
parents où ils vivent leur adolescence
et surtout leurs premières amours
- le vent grâce à lui présente le
paradis en fait il y en a qui veulent
pas que nous on aille là bas mais bon on
y va quand même
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
entre copains dans un manga ou parle
très facilement la sexualité les bains
grèce a atterri
un petit peu de liberté pour cacher les
moeurs dans notre bonne
garde c'est bien contenir là dedans
parce qu'il ya quand vous entendez le
music est tous là
si tu allais avec un homme dans son
barda tu peux te trouver un cerf
[Musique]
je m'aperçois mais je suis dans mon
bagage de pn et la bb
encore et ali moi c'est ça il dit si
c'est le bandeau de mon frère et le
bagage c'est ma liberté
présicé mois berba j'ai construit mais
panda juste à côté là et quand j'ai fini
mon mandat c'est pour les filles
je vais tous les jours j'ai 14 et dont
on voit les bandas c'était paradis sur
terre
[Musique]
ici on est dans la france mais pas la
france métropolitaine jeudi qu' on est à
dix mille kilomètres je crois je sais
pas comment c'est pour les adolescentes
de la métropole mais la vie d'un
adolescent à mayotte moi je trouve que
c'est ici un avantage de vivre ici dans
cette partie de la france où les jeunes
sont vives dans les mangas au lieu de
vivre avec les parents
moi je considère que le banc gaza
représente le passage de l'enfant à
l'adulte parce que
généralement un jeune vient dans un
banga mois ce qui vient juste d'entamer
son adolescence ou même l'un plutôt y en
a qui commencent à la jetée devant comme
ça
magaye il ya ma gêne ou bang bang à yaya
y aller où
c'est une plante qui se promène dans la
rue avec un petit cochon sous le bras un
pass à un peu plus tu veux que les
autres lui demande où l'avez-vous trouvé
ben je gagnais à la kermesse pour le
petit cochon
c'est pas toi qu'est-ce qu'ils ont
conquis les blood mais bon les genres de
voix ils disent oui j'ai pleuré de son
sel qui sont le plus éloignés 107 qui
sort le plus aimé des choses comme ça
j'ai pas des typhons les blacks parce
qu'ils aillent gallepe l'aude
j'ai pas moi personnellement j'aime bien
le plan et j'en ai rencontré une odyssée
mais j'en ai rencontré lui aussi qu'il
est brune et
le comble c'est le meilleur - ce qui
s'est bien décorée d'attirer les filles
chez toi la fille va venir ils vont même
pouvoir coller des photos à eux qui
seront pas osé faire si c'était chez les
parents
serhat une mère ou un père vient te voir
d'importants gains parce qu'ils risquent
de trouver en train de faire je sais pas
trop quoi des choses qui va pas trop
aimer c'est pour ça que lorsqu'on
construit des murs est souvent on fait
des grosses fenêtre pour pouvoir passer
la fille est partie en cas de besoin
[Musique]
ce soit des copines qui m'ont promis de
tout
il se passe des choses dans les mangas
c'est pas que dix missions way label'vie
ont inscrit des fêtes entre protée toumi
a aussi écouté avec les filles
finalement c'est une autre façon de
mener sa jeunesse de vivre une vie que
tout le monde ne connaît pas quoi
[Musique]
ça travaille le moment
dans l'un des cas qu'à 2 où il
n'est ni nous
ni nos
lacets mes amis tous formats c'est là
c'est mon frère à toutes les deux fait
cette de banane c'est la première balle
à qui j'ai construit je suis très
heureux pour eux
je vous dis ce n'est qu'un fils qui vous
dire allez vous ou je t'aime
c'est 10 de tellement de choses necker
patrick thomas
pour m
ok
[Musique]
m
venez
le fonds dit salut ça pour les bons
gars parce que c'est grâce à lui que
tout va prendre forme le fonds dit en
fait son travail c'est dj jeu venir là
pour donner le plan du vendredi ouest tu
fais comme ceci là c'est la bonne
position par rapport au vent si il fait
du que c'est un bon jour samedi peu
après ton bagage mais il va durer
longtemps
[Musique]
on sait bien que ma mère m'avait ma mère
m'a dit un jour arriver un
va te chercher une autre maison que le
mien fait
m² mois sur toi de chez moi j'ai comparé
ce avec quoi faites comme les oiseaux au
fait quand même loin l'âge de voler le
kit comme ça fait ça me rappelle ça
ça vous paraît en même temps un pays
chaud quand même temps
quelque part
nous apprenons
à ne compter que sur eux parce que
construire une bande à l'âge de 12 ans
ça me paraît chez panisse
ego test enfin si
tous ces métiers
[Musique]
là j'ai dû
balayer
ce soit on va faire un voulait parce
qu'on est content pour bareback et enfin
pris la décision de construction banga
le voulait c'est une tradition dans les
mangas ou les jeunes il nous apporte un
peu de bananes de manioc du poulet tout
ce qu'ils veulent le soir comme ça ils
invitent les deux copains les copines
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il va moi
[Rires]
non mais elle est pas vraiment ma chérie
c'est comme une sorte de grand mère a
fait mais fait des plaisanteries comme
ça ouais tout ceci on plaisante même des
trucs concernant ma vie personnelle je
dis ma vie sexuelle des choses comme ça
on en parle ensemble parce qu'en fait
ici à m c'est c'est pas plus et pas sur
tous les parents qui explique par
exemple la vie sexuelle la vie dans les
bagages osant à leurs enfants mais c'est
plutôt les grands mères les grands
perdants on trouve des grands mecs qui
parlent avec nos leurs petits-enfants de
la lie lesté par exemple ou des choses
comme ça leur dit web à les protéger ou
vous fait pas n'importe quoi on se pose
beaucoup de questions genre ouais c'est
commencer la première fois avec une 9 ou
des choses comme ça toutes les questions
de droit fait c'est quoi c'est quoi une
fille c'est quoi je sais pas le saxo
féminin j'ai jamais vu c'est comment
comment il faut s'y prendre avec elle
quelle bêtise il faut pas faire et esca
voilà quoi
la sexualité c on ne parle pas
facilement
par la métropole
alors non pour l'entente n'a pas dit que
on n'a pas dit qu'il faut être
pas fait l'amour machine
dès que je vous reçois une fille chez
moi moi je vais chercher même si je ne
pose pas la question dès le premier soir
que ça mais je sors avec elle durant un
bon moment disons qu'au bout de comment
comme ça je vais commencer à lui dire
voilà bon parce que jusqu'à trois mois
on aura fait tu s'embrasser ou peut-être
à la limite ce quart est un petit peu
mais ça va s'arrêter là et au bout de
ces trois mois c'est là que je vais
commencer à lui dire voilà est-ce que tu
as tout tu préfère garder ta virginité
août et déjà plus vierges comme ça moi
je pose lui poser la question après elle
elle va me répondre si elle me dit que
voilà elle va préférer la carte moi j'ai
rien j'ai bien tenté quoi je ne
m'arrêtais justin aux préliminaires le
gua c'est le fait de faire l'amour sans
pénétration parce que les jeunes
mahorais is this beaucoup ça juste parce
que lis peuvent pas rentrer et de pans
de déflorer la fiba ils font ça ils
pratiquent scène c'est le fait de justo
tout comme sa sentence en panne et rien
du tout
un certain plaisir mais il ya aussi
d'avis parce que s'il a eu plus les
garçons et jacques une barre a pris la
fière et risque de tomber à 7 et ça
aussi ça pose des problèmes on a quinze
ans mais on va souvent dans les bon
d'accord il ya toujours des accidents et
qui arrêtait tout animal à des casses
voilà les accidents y tombons 7 à 7
sans le vouloir premièrement si non
notre culture ici c'est ya là des gardes
et la virginité est alors qu'eux ils
peuvent perdre leur peuvent perdre leur
virginité en le vendant le bon gars
c'est pour ça que c'est
on en connaît des jeunes filles en 3e
sont des gens simples qui
font leurs études ne continue pas
à cause des sacs à main et pour la
personne qu'ils défloreront une fille
qui fait une somme colossale
c'est pour ça qu'il faut faut être très
prudent
il faut être plus d'emplois avec sa
salle rigole pas on vous savez avec la
religion on voudrait avec une fille et
plh saillie c'est l'ennui donc enfin je
préfère éviter un petit peu des vicois
et garder les études et c'est tout les
filles sont à la maison et les mecs les
ils sont dans leurs bagages
parce qu'ils peuvent pas tout cela est
habité dans dents chez leur mère quoi si
j'étais un long jeu grand père et au
cerveau comme un singe j'aimerais
cultiver des choses dit
que les fans ne peuvent pas tous
pouvaient gêner reconstruire les maisons
mais postule aussi un banga dans
lesquels je dormirai avec mes meilleurs
amis mais malgré cela je suis une fille
avec mes corvée mais ceci est un
problème à comme j'aimerais apple
[Musique]
à riom
tu as fait connaissance avec les bains
c'est lui qui a parlé 1 chef boucher un
problème je suis je
dit tim intimity
je vais l'amener en cause je veux le
donnait à 5 ans oui à moi j'aimerais
bien voir commencer et tu vas la mener
en même temps la
victime a tu vas pas effectué une petite
et moi je pleurais
ouais
un beat moi je peux aller au prévenu
j'ai crié je peux tu poses
g faire le point jusqu'à ce que tout le
monde disait faut que tu veux bien le
pas ce que ton copei peut pas vivre sans
toi
même et tu vas pas pour target csu un
parti
tient ça sera bien
[Musique]
je t'aime un jour mon prince viendra car
mon regard a croisé son regard j'ai su
que c'était toi qui fera battre mon
coeur plus que mille fois alors c'est là
que j'ai compris tu jamais plus de ma
vie je ne me réveille notre personne
mais hélas tu ne me crois pas mais tu ne
sais pas à quel point je brûle d'un mot
pour toi et j'espère qu'un jour mon rêve
se réalisera ce rêve c'est d'être avec
toi je t'aime signé un bébé d'amour
commencent à ce
que tu joues à à cette passion
ça juste
[Musique]
et
[Rires]
c'est tous les états unis qui font mal
lorsqu'on fait des fêtes ici et calvet
talent comme ça vers 3 heures du matin
tout le monde s'est un peu fatigué on
s'endort un petit peu fort sur les
cartes et d'un coup tout le monde qu'il
déchaîne ça tape ça rigole ça où ça joue
quoi et s'il ya des fils est encore pire
parce que là on est bien content atteint
à la laddh sorte de taper se méfie aussi
ça rigole pas ça ne rigole pas du tout
parce qu'un art voilà c'est le jeu et on
y va quoi même si c'est notre copine
mais aussi ça ta copine ou pas mais on
tape c'est la règle du jeu on tape aussi
fort avec les filles qu'avec les garçons
ça arrive que ce soit un cadeau du go
ce genre de choses là oui l ou r match à
balma
n'a pas
moi je prends mes affaires pour aller
aux daïras et le daïla pour moi c'est
une façon de me faire désirer ou
d'ailleurs bon je vais faire je vais
montrer que voilà moi je suis celui qui
qui sait chanter qui sait mieux le
danser pour me faire désirer parce que
tout au tout il y aura des filles des
gens qui vont regarder quoi et donc là
j'ai je vais faire le maximum pour me
faire désirer
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
là
hélas
[Applaudissements]
à
m
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
rien n'y fit danser bien sa chambre déjà
les avons vu lors des mois -
la plus jolie fille du couple à et voilà
est le plus heureux dans votre bagage et
quitter vers vienne
[Musique]
oh
ce matin là nous partons de déchets de
notre banc gars pour aller chez ma mère
dans le but d'aller prendre votre petit
déjeuner mois donc mais aimer deux fait
est là bas on a trouvé ma mère comme ça
et
puis dit qu'est ce qu'on va faire c'est
aujourd'hui parce que par exemple à midi
l'heure du déjeuner on va pas être à la
maison lui expliquer tout ça et voilà
quoi
[Musique]
elle dit que parfois il y va dans notre
banger pour nous retrouver ben et nous
trouvons sleep est comme ça et tu vois
ça je veux pas trop mais ceci dit
lorsque je lis alain julié annoncé que
j'allais construire mon manga elle a dit
pourquoi ça pourquoi tu décides de te
quitter d'aller loin là-bas en plus
c'est bien éloigné de là où elle est et
tout de suite elle à dire mon père ou
vas-y agrandi la maison pour que ton
enfant puisse rester avec nous ici je
veux pas qu'il parte là-bas on compte
sur notre père mais notre père il a des
enfants ailleurs aussi lui l'a plusieurs
fois m'a fait c'est pour ça peut-être
qu'il n'a pas trop voulu faire ce que ma
mère lui a demandé je sais
pas ce que avoir plusieurs femmes ça
sous-entend avant aussi de l'argent pour
pour veiller sur les enfants
mais elle personnellement elle aurait
préféré que
et restait toujours ici
[Musique]
2 1
au t1
[Musique]
avant j'étais surtout pour la polygamie
mais
vu tout ce que ma mère
vit avec la la polygamie je suis plus
trop trop pauvre pour ce à quoi ceci dit
bon je suis bien intégré c'est d'avoir
plusieurs copines en même temps ou des
choses comme ça mais la polygamie non
parce que ça fait souffrir les enfants
un jour comme ça je peux aller dans la
rue ou dans un autre village je me
retrouve avec un fichu très bien la
drague comme ça et puis le moment on
parle comme ça ou même après j'aurais
très bien pu faire des choses avec elle
et me rendre compte que finalement c'est
une mission à moi et là ce serait pas
très bien quoi
je crois que à mayotte beaucoup de gens
ont construit leur banque à deux blocs
et les ss dans la maison familiale parce
que souvent on est nombreux dans la
famille et il sait très bien qu'un qu'un
jeune garçon et il est un peu un tout
petit décalage entre lui et sa soeur et
tous les deux hommes dorment dans le
même lit ou dans la même chambre alors
que on sait qu'à l'adolescence le garçon
disait il change de comportement il a
certainement envie ou des choses comme
ça qui font que il risque de faire
l'inceste
du web de commettre sa
[Musique]
c'est moi c'est beaucoup
la vie de célibataire est superbe n'est
ce pas beatty
bonvoisin
à huy bon moi je trouve que c'est bien
papa je suis tranquille je m'amuse quand
j'ai envie quand j'ai pas envie voilà
ah bon
bon ben je préfère avoir une copine à la
tétée d'accord avec moi ou pas
ces cours de l'or
je n'ai pas aimé avoir un bon gâteau par
mois oui 6 non m'imagine c'était dingue
assis à votre
choix
en tout cas mon mandat c'est mon nid
d'amour
[Musique]
n'aime pas ça va intéresser mon nid
d'amour assez
je pense la même chose que moi
ah bon
deux classes quête d ici t'as pas envie
de partir des voix ah ouais
cette
saloperie zatko pourtant
voilà c'est là où j'ai passé des moments
voulu
away
vraiment que je voudrais pas des moments
de plaisir et
ça sera toujours là propre à
bon ben je crois que vous avez compris
faut que j'y aille là mon boulot c'est
mauvais